vers qui pourrait être long alors que
les russes continuent d'afficher une
posture conquérante hier lors d'un forum
économique tournée vers l'asie vladimir
poutine a pris la parole fustigeant
l'attitude des occidentaux menaçant même
de suspendre les livraisons
d'hydrocarbures aux européens en réponse
à la proposition du gel des prix du gaz
dans le camp occidental les ministres de
la défense des pays alliés 1 sont en
train de se retrouver en allemagne
réunion pour organiser leur soutien aux
capacités militaires du craignent n les
américains par la voix de lloyd austin
on l'annoncé déjà une aide financière
supplémentaire est conséquente écouter
dans un monde où de grandes puissances
piétine des frontières par la force
notre soutien aux droits de l'ukraine à
se défendre ne faiblira pas face à
l'adversité
hier le président a donné son accord
pour une nouvelle tranche d aide à
l'ukraine d'un montant de 675 millions
de dollars